what's going on guys this is Rob and the
X-Men are officially declaring war on
humanity and the ending of this is crazy
because this is the Fall of the House of
X essentially the official beginning of
the end so what this does here is this
picks up with Cyclops right he says I
have this recurring dream and I know
it's just a dream but it feels real I'm
being dragged into an angry town I don't
know what I did to deserve the hangman
Maybe deserving has got nothing to do
with it maybe it's just fate and he says
I get to say my peace but it matters not
the fix is in the judge is someone I
recognize someone I thought I knew and
so Colossus says guilty on all these
counts my oh my look at them all and the
Cyclops says but he throws me to the
Wolves Justice quote unquote will be
Swift and so he says I should be scared
but I'm not I'm an innocent man the
world drops out from under my feet but I
do not fall and then he wakes up and he
says I'm not doing much more than in my
dreams I was thousands of miles away
from the Hellfire Gala when I felt Jean
die but I felt Jean die before and death
doesn't suit her okay so after that he
says orcus has me right where they want
me on trial and all of mutum are my
codefendants I'm playing along buying
the resistance time to strike back what
makes the orcus threat so Insidious is
the way they made everyone cheer at our
suffering humans like their symbolism
this is Paris where they tried Magneto
this time the trial will go their way
but the war will not okay let's get you
guys caught up on what's Happening Here
so those of you guys who have been
following our coverage of fall of X you
guys are totally aware of what's going
on right you guys already know what's
happening this is for people who don't
know who are clicking on this for the
first first time orcus is a governmental
organization composed of guys from Hydra
Advanced ID mechanics former Shield
agents and it's staunchly anti-mutant it
launched an attack against the mutant
population during What's called the
Hellfire golet basically an annual event
where the entirety of the mutant
population chooses a new X-Men team to
represent them it happens every year so
the team changes every year during the
most recent Hellfire Gala orcus launched
a strike against the mutant population
and scattered them to the wind those who
remained on Earth were consistently
being hunted attacked and even killed
and cyclops himself was captured by
orcus his eyes were swn shut and he was
held as a prisoner the rest of
everything that happened will kind of
fill you in along the way so that's why
Cyclops is here he's officially being
put on trial but even he recognizes it's
a kangaroo court and so at that point
you basically switch over to Colossus
and Wolverine two members from exforce
right and what we're told is that the
Cen age was remarkable for the
advancement in mutant technology by
combining their powers into circuits the
mutants formed a nation that was carbon
negative and spanned several worlds
there was a consensus among historians
that the primordial circuit in mutant
technology was the quote unquote fast
ball special the name of the physical
attack where Colossus pitched Wolverine
with uncanny accuracy at a Target now to
specify the statement about his spanning
several worlds again people who are
familiar with fex know what's going on
there was a point where a portion of the
mutant population which we don't have to
go into specifics you can check out the
playlist to get the details on it in
effect had taken up residents on Mars
and so mutants now lived on both Mars
and Earth so that's what they're talking
about when they say it spans several
worlds influence Spann even more worlds
than that but we kind of pick up here
with Colossus and Wolverine once they're
in the sewers right where it's hold and
the dark days following the third hell
fight Gala Colossus and Logan were
infiltrating the sewers under the Paris
courthouse and their dark moods LED them
to invert the fast ball special though
they were having a difficult time coming
up with a name for it and literally this
guy right just like this agent of orcus
who tries to shoot Colossus because the
guy's an idiot and has no idea that
Colossus has osmium metal skin which you
can't shoot with laser guns and Photon
Torpedoes so like he just throws this
guy like a pinata and wolver rain just
like lashes this dude it's kind of a
cool thing right instead of it being the
fast ball special where Colossus throws
wolver rain it's like the pinata special
where Colossus throws an enemy at
Wolverine and then Wolverine kills him I
kind of love it that's one of the things
you guys are going to notice the X-Men
just start massacring everybody right I
mean like they don't care like they stop
pulling punches it's crazy so what
wolverine says of course right like
that's a terrible named heat I thought
the Russians were poets there's a little
bit of back and forth here and Colossus
talks about how he's not really feeling
very poetic now this was part of fall of
X and it was part of the X Force story
that just kind of fizzled out and
seemingly went nowhere but in effect
Colossus has a brother named uh Rasputin
and what Rasputin had done is he had
basically secured the abilities of a
mutant who has the power to make anybody
do anything as long as this guy writes
it down and what he did is he used his
powers to force Colossus to turn against
the exforce team right basically turn
against the mutant population and so
Colossus is still just kind of one
feeling guilty about that but two pissed
off about it now Rasputin and those guys
have been dealt with now is just turning
all that anger and all that rage to
orcus and I got to tell you guys man
unless you've been a longtime reader of
Marvel Comics watching Colossus be
pissed off son son son it is a sight to
behold I mean this guy almost never
loses his Timber but when he does Katie
Bar the Door this guy
man this dude knows how to let loose but
well the thing about this is that we
pick back up with Cyclops again as he's
being held within just like an
interrogation room and this guy comes in
and says like there's somebody here to
see you and initially Cyclops makes a
kind of joke thinking that it might be
Gan gray because remember during the
events of fall of X genan gray was one
of the first mutants to die now she did
kind of come back to a degree and she is
sort of floating out there but in terms
of her returning and operating as part
of the quote unquote X-Men resistance
she's not really in that capacity right
now we'll cover that as time goes on but
what we end up finding out is that it's
Dr Alia Gregor and Karima shapandar
right Omega Sentinel so we'll talk about
Omega Sentinel here in a second but Dr
alot Gregor honestly that's a name that
we haven't heard since like the
beginnings of Jonathan Hickman's run so
the whole idea behind Alia Gregor is
that her and her husband worked on the
initial orcus Forge right like the
mother mold Forge basically a giant
space station that orbited the Sun that
just created Sentinels and I mean it's
not even one of those things where it's
like Days of Future Past where it
created like thousands of them no no no
this thing cranked out hundreds of
thousands of them right like just
several orders of magnitude beyond what
you would need to quell the entirety of
the superhero community on earth like it
was just it was crazy how much they had
but during one of the attacks that went
down her husband was killed by the X-Men
Strike Force ever since then the idea of
her working on orcus wasn't academic it
be became personal and now she had a
personal Vendetta in seeing the
destruction of the mutant population on
Earth now Karima was it one point a
member of like the Earthbound mutant
Community but she is in effect a kind of
cyborg right like really the most
advanced aspects of a sentinel combined
with like human mutant DNA so she's
literally just like a living machine
she's pretty capable and very very
powerful up until this point we haven't
really seen everything she's capable of
but you will and when you do your jaw is
going to hit the
floor because she is nuts but what
happens is as they start talking there's
this amazing conversation that goes down
because what I want you guys to keep in
mind for those of you guys who know
about it this is very very similar to
God loves man kills right that story
where William Striker and the purifiers
were just killing mutants
indiscriminately because they believed
God wanted them to so the cool thing
here right is Cyclops says Dr Gregor
this might surprise you to hear but
you've been on my mind and her response
oh D tell have you been replaying making
me a widow over and over and his
response no I have no memory of leading
the assault on your mother mold I've
been thinking about the price of war and
she says some of us paid more than
others now the reason why Cyclops
doesn't remember it is because Cyclops
died in that initial attack and one of
the things that mutants those of you
guys who were who didn't really follow
the X-Men Mythos one of the things that
mutants were able to to do is they were
able to resurrect their own the
difference is that when a person was
resurrected you could choose what
Memories they kept and in fact you could
even modify their powers if you wanted
to so it was really less resurrection
and more just purely God creation but
what ended up happening here is when
Cyclops was brought back his memories of
the strike were removed and so because
of that he doesn't recall anything that
went down so again like she knows it
took place and him just saying I don't
remember doesn't really make any
difference and so when she says that
some of us had paid more than others he
says I know grief is a heavy set of
chains and then she just starts
screaming at him right she's like don't
you dare right let me tell you because
of our sacrifice the last human has died
because of mutant aggression I'm not
having a hard time don't pretend to know
me and that's where he tells her well
it's my mistake I thought I smelled a
whiff of bourbon on your coffee and so
he says if not to discuss the war why
are you here and why is Omega Sentinel
accompanying you and so she responds as
she says we're here because I wanted to
see you to tell you that I lost a battle
and a husband but I won the war and his
response I think you came here for
something else a human interaction with
a man experiencing his own profound
grief and he says and what happens after
when the last mutant is dead under your
heels and she says I'm not sure I
suppose Mankind exhales and and lives
happily ever after and in turn Cyclops
smiles and she thinks that he's smiling
at her and she's like why do you find
that funny and he's like my question
wasn't for you Dr Gregor and that's when
Omega Sentinel says we should leave
because here's the thing to understand
Right From karima's perspective right
the way that she's been operating all
this time it's better to be on the
devil's right hand than in his past but
the reality here is that orcus wants to
eradicate all mutants not just the ones
that worked against them but the
entirety of the mutant population so
this is effectively Cyclops telling
Omega Sentinel when they're done with us
they're going to come for you and the
question you have to ask yourself is
before that time comes do you really
believe that they won't do it do you
really believe that orcus will not take
you out because they will they have a
staunch hatred for Humanity you will
Ally yourself with them you will help
them the entirety of the mutant
population will be destroyed maybe even
a few superheroes who decide to work
alongside mutants and trying to end the
threat of orcus and then when the smoke
settles and it's all said and done this
woman is going to be standing next to
you with a gun to your head and she's
going to say nothing personal but we do
have to take care of all the mutants
she's going to pull the trigger and
Humanity will be the last one standing
with a Smoking Gun so do you really want
to be on the business end of a weapon
pointed at your face so it's a really
really smart kind of maneuver because
what it does
is it sews the seeds of doubt it sews in
this idea that now she's potentially
paranoid and so what we end up doing is
we switched back over to CAA and to
Xavier now Professor Xavier for those of
you guys who weren't Following fall of X
this guy largely just remained on ccoa
part of it was just guilt over the fact
that when orgus initially launched the
attack what they did is they told
Professor Xavier if you do not tell
every mutant on this island to go
through the cran gateways basically
portals and leave like the entirety of
planet Earth we will wipe out all of
them right now and so Xavier did that
right thinking they were going to some
kind of a safe haven but once they left
he was no longer able to detect their
presence anywhere right and presumably
his powers had extended far enough to
Mars and the belief is that that's where
they had gone potentially somewhere else
but using his abilities he wasn't able
to sense their presence at all because
there is a kind of Technology that's
ingrained and built into mutants to
where he can detect their presence
anywhere in seemingly the known universe
or like anywhere the Ken Gates can go to
and so because of that he's been
operating all this time under the belief
that the mutant he s away are dead the
reality is they're not and that's one of
the things that we learned about fall of
X an army of mutants
250,000 strong is just waiting out there
to be recalled back to Earth it's crazy
so what ends up happening is this guy
just la es out right no more and he says
it's time and so what he does is he
contacts Rasputin for now again for
those of you guys who hadn't really
picked up with everything Rasputin 4 was
from an alternate timeline called sins
of sinister the story was not that great
it's not overly important the thing
about Rasputin 4 though is that she is a
mutant that actually has a variety of
powers under herself she can make
herself intangible like kitty Pride she
has the skin of Colossus I think she can
teleport like Nightcrawler I don't
remember all her abilities but she has
like four or five different abilities of
X-Men so she's literally a one-woman
army like this woman could take down a
whole group of orcus Sentinels by
herself it's just how capable she is but
you have Xavier who contacts her he says
Rasputin for I have need of you and she
says but I'm above the courthouse I have
a critical role in the rescue mission
for Cyclops and the response of Xavier I
know you have been trying to split your
time between our work and the X-Men I
promise you we can save them all but
only if you join right now and he says
You must trust me we can fix everything
and she says very well and flies away
right she literally leaves Colossus and
Wolverine to their fate she was supposed
to be the one to get him out and that
Wolverine and Colossus were going to be
rescued at the same time because they
were kind of the rescue mission which
truth to tell are about two of the best
people you could have try to break you
out one guy with nearly indestructible
skin and and one dude with an
indestructible skeleton and a healing
Factor who literally can't die so like
it would have been amazing if we gotten
to see that prison break but what isend
up happening is that when they contact
reutin she's nowhere to be found
literally she doesn't answer because
she's gone and then wolver rain sniffing
things out realizes soldiers are coming
right he's like cordite something else
big and heavy rumbling towards US orcus
soldiers bust through the sewer wall
with an electromagnet pin both these
guys to the wall right so literally it's
what the smartest things they could have
done both these guys are stuck to the
wall and then one of them just like runs
up on Wolverine and it's like for
Humanity and blast this dude with a
flamethrower and so seemingly these guys
are stuck these guys are pinned but then
rescue comes from the most unlikely of
places ladies and gentlemen Nightcrawler
Nightcrawler teleports in right takes
out all these guards rescues wolver rain
and then at that point that's when you
know that things are about to get dark
because it's not one of these things
where wolver and Colossus scare these
guys no they start killing them like
they just start just massacring these
guys and literally Colossus says let
these orcus cowards run and tell the
Marauders in red that anybody aligned
with them will die squirming under my
metal foot and Wolverine says no more
fear from this moment on they are the
ones who shall fear and the response of
Nightcrawler then to war right so
literally they are Marching to war at
that point you switch over to Cyclops
right and you basically get just like
this prosecutor more or less who makes
this case in saying that not only have
has Humanity proven Beyond a reasonable
doubt that mutants are a menace but that
they're an invasive foreign species the
secret rulers of kcoa the so-called
quiet counil basically the leaders of
the mutant government admitted as much
when they stole Mars away and turned it
into a home for mutant's Wayward cousins
Cyclops admits he is the leader of the
X-Men all these crimes stem from his
poisoned fruit the prosecution rests
your honor literally all the prosecution
does is they show up and say those guys
are dicks you know it I know it we rest
our case and so in return the judge is
like the defense May begin and that's
when Cyclops is like it's a kangaroo
court the fix is in right The Jig Is up
like it's just one of those things where
like he knew he was never going to get a
fair trial and that was never going to
happen right like he knew that he was
going to be found guilty by Humanity
it's just ricked and no one's going to
say anything because Humanity wants to
see the mutants prosecuted right so
that's one of the things corruption is
only ever a problem when people disagree
with it when people agree with it well I
mean you know that's just kind of how it
goes sometimes so that's one of the
crazy things that's taking place here
because he says I will offer no defense
your honor I'm not dignifying any of
that nonsense with the response I know
there's good in humanity but I am not
being prosecuted by it and the response
to the judge like I've warned that if
you follow through by representing
yourself self and some kind of a
non-answer non-- tactic you will be
found guilty and the response to Cyclops
I can only be judged by one soul and I
do not think you'd like to meet her I.E
his wife because I'll tell you guys
right now man there's only there's only
one thing more terrifying to Cyclops
then the entirety of humanity waging a
war against the mutant population
watching all of his friends just being
massacred and one Fel swop you know what
that thing is a pissed off wife the one
thing every man fears so in response to
this we basically jump over to orcus who
are just kind of celebrating everything
that's going on with the idea of the
mutant population being found guilty but
notice this right Karima is watching
she's watching it all and while she
doesn't make a particular move per se
what she does do is she tells Nimrod to
go kill the island of kkaa because
remember the island of CAA is a sentient
Island right it's one of the things they
did in sin a Sinister they literally
fired Juggernaut through his head I
think and and then in turn just like
lobotomized him right and so this really
appears more of a trap than anything
else we don't know that it is because we
don't really know what Karima is
thinking we just kind of have to
interpret it but assuming that she knew
everything that was going on when she
sends Nimrod the ultimate Sentinel to
this place literally kcoa just spits
Amber all over this guy and it freezes
him in place at that point kakoa as the
island stands up out of the ground and
it imprisons Nimrod down in the pit now
for those of you guys who don't know the
pit is a place on ccoa which is almost
kind of like an other-dimensional realm
when you're sent there there's seemingly
no way to get back the only way to get
out is to do what saber-tooth did was to
actually make your kind of essence part
of the pit itself and then you can
control it which we do need to go back
and finish covering that saber-tooth
story because it was amazing saber-tooth
oh dude it was so good that saber-tooth
story was dope but in the face of the
fact that nrod tried to destroy it ccoa
comes to the realization quick fast and
in a hurry there's going to be more
right once they realize that like nrod
is disabled they're either going to send
another one which they don't really have
one as capable as this one or they're
just going to send an army of Sentinels
to destroy this thing so this guy jumps
up right leaps out of the island itself
and then just like goes down into the
water at that point you have Dr Alia
right who jumps in with basically these
Sentinels right the Stark Sentinels that
were being used by orcus right basically
just because of the fact that fa long in
the Iron Man Comics had basically taken
over Tony Stark's company Fe long
working with orcus allowed them to
access Sentinels that were built using
Stark Tech and she basically tells them
we were lulled into a false sense of
security when kcoa first popped up and
the mutants first appeared with their
government they came to us and they said
we have medicines that can cure any
mental illness we have medicines that
can prolong your life all we ask in
return for these is that you allow any
and all mutants in your Nation to live
freely in ccoa some countries did some
countries didn't for those countries
that didn't exforce got sent in and they
were literally an extraction team that
brought those mutants out but then the
whole big propaganda scheme that was
created by orcus which was never true is
that mutant kind was actually killing
Humanity because what orcus did is they
actually poisoned the medicines that
ccoa was sending out to humanity and
then when people started dying orcus
said see we told you guys that mutants
were the bad guys and completely turned
public opinion against the mutant
population and so what she's doing now
is she's building on that right she's
like ccoa has been proven to be an
invasive alien species and orcus is
pulling it from the Earth's garden and
she literally tells them this will not
be pleasant this is a war against the
mutant population there will be
collateral damage but unfortunately in
every conflict there is so stay with us
we know it will be rough but at the end
of the day Humanity will prevail Freedom
will prevail so it's just one of these
things where it's just so pro-human and
because public opinion is so anti-
mutant they can get away with it now for
Kitty pride and for wolver rain and for
Colossus they're actually rescued and
brought in by Rogue and Gambit who have
just kind of been out there doing their
own respective things but the questions
as asked by Gambit what happened to Iron
Man's big plant the mysterium armor that
he was supposed to have and all that
kind of stuff cuz I know a lot of you
guys are probably asking that question
right the response of kitty Pride he's
executing it right now we were not ready
for the invasion yet but it's all
falling apart we have to go now we're
over London there are several Gates I
can use to rally the troops they drop
her out now the Iron Man tians are
coming out those that's actually
continuing this month so like all that
stuff is going going to tie directly
into the Fall of the House of X but
Kitty Pride dropping through the cran
Gates because for reasons that still
haven't been fully explained she's the
only one who can the gates are closed to
mutants mutants cannot use the Ken Gates
I probably should have specified that
earlier but Kitty Pride can't using her
access to the Gates She rallies the
troops right she literally goes to like
Iron Man and Emma Frost right who are
basically Mas rating as a married couple
make sure you guys check the follow
back's playlist to get caught up on that
because I know some of you guys are
probably like
wait what yeah so make sure you check
that out because it's dope the Iron Man
Tian is the best Story part of fall of X
it's phenomenal but but
nonetheless right she goes to those guys
and it's like mysterium armor now she
goes to Juggernaut and it was like you
got to be unstoppable man like she's
literally just rallying everybody she
can she goes to Kamala Khan for some
reason doesn't make any sense and then
she goes to like the rest of the
Avengers right basically grabbing
everyone she can where she can now a lot
of that's because under Captain America
and the uncanny Avengers that Team Works
directly alongside the mutants not
publicly but privately because if the
Avengers are seen working alongside the
mutant population then public opinion
will turn against the Avengers so it's
one of those things where it's like we
can help you but we can't let people
know we're actually doing it they're
putting skin in the game right I mean
it's not to say that they're just being
lazy and you know just being like I mean
we can feed you information but I mean
we got no dog in this fight no no no no
they're putting skin in the game but
what you end up doing is you have kitty
Pride who goes to Lorna danne also known
as Polaris the daughter of Magneto
because in the face of Magneto's death
during Judgment Day no one has control
over the electromagnetic spectrum
anywhere near what he does and while
Polaris is powerful she's really
inconsistent there's been stories where
she's been shown to be able to overpower
Magneto and there's been stories where
she's been shown to be less powerful
than Magneto so really it's only a
matter of time to know what's going to
happen here but what this does right as
we wind down this story what this does
is it switches out to a space station
called nowhere it is not the Guardians
of the Galaxy getting that right out of
the way right now right on the far side
of Jupiter within a decapitated
Celestial head in ancient evil lurks The
Brood are the most hated parasites in
the universe and we were told not long
ago they fell under the control of a
mutant named Brew brew was a member of
The Brew race who was a mutant but
resided on Earth Jean Gray saved his
life and in the absence of brood
leadership anybody leading this race brw
stepped up and took their place to give
you guys perspective on what this means
because Laura danne shows up here right
she says Gan is dead Brew those of us
who live we resist are you ready to go
to war the respons of Brew yes Jean save
me save these brood and the response of
Polaris is then to war to give you guys
perspective of what this means imagine
that the mutant population had under its
control the Xenomorphs from the alien
film and imagine they unleashed the
entire race of those things on earth God
only knows what's going to happen which
we'll find out later with that being
said guys we're going to bring this to
an end if you guys need to get caught up
on fall of X make sure you guys click
this link to the playlist list and I
will catch you all later peace